مع اقتراب الوجود العسكري الأمريكي في
أفغانستان
من نهايته ومع استمرار طالبان
في كسب
المزيد والمزيد من الأرض ، فإن العديد من الأفغان
مرعوبون مما قد يحدث لهم وهم
يبحثون في كل خيار ممكن
لمحاولة الخروج من البلاد هنا في
مطار اسطنبول  وجدنا واحدة من تلك
القصص العديدة التي
حاولت فيها هذه المحاولات اليائسة الفرار من أفغانستان للهروب
من طالبان
، قال مجموعة من 16 أفغانيًا ينتمون
لعائلة ممتدة إنهم اشتروا تذاكر
لحضور مباراة يورو 2020 في سانت بطرسبرغ
الشهر الماضي سمحت لهم بالمشاركة.
رحلة طيران من أفغانستان
إلى روسيا مع توقف في تركيا
دون الحاجة إلى
تأشيرات دخول ، كانت الخطة هي التقدم بطلب للحصول على اللجوء
عندما وصلوا إلى تركيا
لكن تقطعت بهم السبل في
منطقة العبور هنا
لمدة ثلاثة أسابيع تقريبًا ، إنه
وضع مفجع.
إرسال صور لمقاطع فيديو
لما مروا به على أطفال ينامون على
الأرض
، ويبدو أن بعض أفراد المجموعة يحتاجون إلى
رعاية طبية
عاجلة  استمع إلى أحدهم وهو
يصف ما مر به ،
فنحن نعيش هنا بدون طعام وماء
وحليب لطفلنا
ليس لدينا مكان للنوم ونأكل على
الأرض
وحجر هربناه من أفغانستان بسبب
وضع يهدد الحياة معه  طالبان ،
لذا جئنا إلى المطار لمحاولة
مقابلة هذه المجموعة ، لكن تم نقلهم منذ ذلك الحين
إلى منطقة احتجاز للهجرة
لا يعرفون ما الذي
سيحدث لهم ما إذا كان
سيسمح لهم بالتقدم بطلب
حالة الحماية المؤقتة في تركيا والتي من شأنها أن
تسمح لهم بتقديم طلب اللجوء في وقت لاحق في
مكان آخر.
سقطوا على طالبان
أحد أقاربهم يقولون إنه قُتل مؤخرًا
على حد تعبير رجل واحد في تلك المجموعة
يقول إن إعادتهم إلى أفغانستان
سيكون بمثابة حكم بالإعدام جمانة كاراتشاي سي
إن إن
اسطنبول.